j'ai peur à chaque fois de mourir je me
dis clairement je honnête je prie chaque
seconde on attend quoi pour pour faire
quelque chose on attend qu'un drame se
passe j'ai 25 ans j'ai une vie devant
moi
bah je pense que les images elles
parlent d'elles-mêmes c'est dramatique
j'ai
je peux même pas vous dire à quel point
à chaque fois je sors tous les jours
j'ai peur et du coup j'ai dû arrêter
d'aller à la fac malheureusement
les personnes handicap moteur tu t'es
déjà retrouvé coincé
m'arrive presque tous les jours mais ça
date pas d'aujourd'hui en 2019 il y
avait encore des rêves je voulais
prendre le RER pour rentrer chez moi le
seul moyen que j'avais de prendre des
escalators il y a un monsieur qui a bien
voulu m'aider et évidemment ça n'a pas
loupé j'ai des gringolé les 20 marches
étant m'a dit que j'avais fait une chute
mortelle